we're going to attempt a partial effect
to me it is quite technically talented
hussein is preparing his theater team
for surgery
he's about to operate on a 31 year old
woman with a suspected cancerous tumor
on her kidney what this is this
patient's ct so the brown is the kidney
and the green is the tumor and it tells
us how many arteries there are which is
that red blood vessel
it was picked up by chance during a
routine pregnancy scan but has grown to
take over half her kidney
it's a complex procedure but mr hussein
has a highly sophisticated tool
to help him
drive the laser lines to the endoscope
port a state-of-the-art robot
the robot is so precise it lets mr
hussein remove the tumor and leave the
rest of the kidney intact
but because we know it's deeper
i might go a bit deeper here
working this way could revolutionize
health care in this country and
hopefully help to tackle the 5 million
strong nhs waiting list this could be
done with the old-fashioned open
incision the patients would have more
post-operative pain
require more painkillers probably be in
hospital for between five and seven days
luckily with the robotic platform we
have they have smaller incisions which
are keyhole incisions and therefore they
could potentially go home the following
day the new boss of the nhs says new
technology will help to ease the burden
on the health service
trust leaders have warned her the
pressure is already enormous when you
have told me as many of you have
just how challenging it is on the ground
when you have described the rising
demand for urgent care in a e and the
community when you have talked about the
intensity of pressures on our workforce
i
have heard you
and i feel those pressures with you nhs
trusts will now look to amanda pritchard
for decisive leadership many many people
are predicting that this is going to be
the most difficult winter for the nhs
what does amanda pritchard need to do to
make sure the nhs can cope we know that
capacity is set for this winter even if
the nhs has more money it won't be able
to recruit more staff because they
simply aren't there but what we do need
to make sure happens is that amanda uses
her influence with the department of
health with treasury with the rest of
government back at friendly park
hospital the patient has been discharged
and is home just 24 hours after her
operation
one more patient off
an ever-growing waiting list
joshi
sky news